>>> NEXT WEDNESDAY THE SENATE
WILL GET A CLASSIFIED BRIEFING
ON UKRAINE AS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION PUSHES FOR AN
ADDITIONAL $37 BILLION IN AID.
BUT THAT COULD BE THE LAST AID
FOR A WHILE.
SOME REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE
SAY IT IS TIME TO CUT OFF KYIV.
CNN MILITARY ANALYST COLONEL
CEDRICK LAYTON JOINS US NOW.
AND THEY SAY THAT RUSSIANS ARE
FIRING DUMMY MISSILES TO EXHAUST
UKRAINE AIR DEFENSES SO THESE
ARE WEAPONS THAT COULD CARRY
NUCLEAR WARHEADS, RIGHT, BUT
THEY'RE NOT.
HOW MUCH IS THIS EXHAUSTING THE
UKRAINIANS?
>> THIS IS A BIG DEAL AND HERE
IS AN ACTUAL DUMMY WARHEAD THAT
THE RUSSIANS SENT OVER TO
UKRAINE.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THERE EXCEPT
THE METAL THAT MAKES THIS THING
UP AND IF IT HITS SOMETHING, IT
COULD DO A LOT OF DAMAGE.
BUT THERE IS NO EXPLOSIVE CAPE
ABILITY HERE.
IT IS JUST IN ESSENCE, EXCEPT
FOR THE FUEL IN THERE, IT IS
JUST A BIG IMPACT.
AND THAT IS GOING TO CREATE A
LARGE PROBLEM AND THE KEY THING
HERE IS THERE ARE SO MANY OF
THESE THAT THEY COULD THROW AT
THE UKRAINIANS AND WHAT
OVERWHELMING THE AIR DEFENSES
AND MAKES IT HARDER FOR THE
UKRAINIANS TO DISCERN WHICH OF
THE MISSILES THEY NEED TO KNOCK
OUT OF THE SKY.
THESE ARE NOT THAT IMPORTANT.
THE ONES THAT ARE IMPORTANT ARE
THE ONES WITH THE REAL WARHEADS.
>> BUT YOU CAN'T TELL JUST FROM
LOOKING AT THAT.
SO THEY HAVE -- THEY HAVE TO
PROTEND AS THOUGH EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEM CONTAINED A NUCLEAR
WARHEAD.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
>> I WANT TO HOME IN THE CITY OF
BACK MOOD.
BECAUSE UKRAINIANS SAID THAT IS
A MAIN TARGET FOR THE RUSSIANS
RIGHT NOW.
SO WHAT IS THE ASSESS.
OF OF FIGHTING THERE.
>> THIS IS IT RIGHT HERE.
IN THE EASTERN PART OF THE
DONETSK REGION THAT UKRAINE
CONTROLS FOR THE MOMENT.
BUT WHAT THE UKRAINIANS NEED TO
DO IS THEY NEED TO PROTECT THE
SOLDIERS THERE AND WHAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE DOING IS THEY'RE
TRYING TO ENCIRCLE THE AREA FROM
THE NORTH AND FROM THE SOUTH.
SO IF THEY DO THIS, THE
UKRAINIANS THAT ARE THERE RISK
BEING CAPTURED OR THE CITY OF
COURSE RISKS BEING TAKEN OVER,
RETAKEN BY THE RUSSIANS.
IF THAT HAPPENS, THE FIGHTING
THAT YOU SEE IN THIS PARTICULAR
CITY IS GOING TO GET REALLY
INTENSE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS, WITH MACHINE
GUNNERS AND BUILDINGS AND FIRING
AT THE OPPOSITION, THAT IS GOING
TO BE A KEY PART OF THE AREA.
AND THE CITY ITSELF HAS A LOT
OF -- A LOT OF ISSUES FROM
PREVIOUS FIGHTING.
ABOUT 70,000 PEOPLE
THE DESTRUCTION HERE IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD, YOU KNOW,
CONTINUE OF COURSE WITH FIGHTING
LIKE THIS AND SO THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL THAT CAN
STAVE THE RUSSIANS OFF BUT THEY
HAVE TO KNOW WHEN AND WHERE THE
RUSSIANS ARE MOVING.
>> RUSSIANS MAY BE GETTING MORE
HELP.
THEY'LL BEEN TALKING WITH
BELARUS IN RECENT DAYS, TELL US
ABOUT THE ROLE BELARUS COULD
PLAY HERE.
>> BELARUS IS TO THE NORTH OF
UKRAINE, IN THE NORTHWESTERN AND
NORTHERN PARTS OF THE COUNTRY,
IT BORDERS RIGHT ALONG HERE AND
IT'S VERY CLOSE TO KYIV, FROM
THE FIRST PART OF THE WAR THAT
WHEN THE RUSSIANS CAME IN TO
CAPTURE THIS AREA, THEY CAPTURED
AREAS AROUND HERE AND AROUND
HERE, THE BIG EFFORT WAS
DESIGNED TO ACTUALLY GO IN AND
TRY TO TAKE KYIV, THEY WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL IN DOING THAT BUT
IF THE RUSSIANS AND THE
BELARUSIANS COME TOGETHER AGAIN
AND IT BECOMES PART OF THE
RUSSIAN ARMY THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY OPEN UP ANOTHER
FRONT AND THAT OTHER FRONT COULD
MOVE AGAINST KYIV ONCE AGAIN SO
THIS IS VERY DANGEROUS THING AND
WHEN THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE
MINISTER MET WITH HIS
COUNTERPART IT WAS VERY CLEAR
THEY'RE TRYING TO ESTABLISH A
RELATIONSHIP AND EVEN DEEPEN THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT ALREADY EXISTS
BETWEEN THE TWO COUNTRIES.
BELARUS IS RUSSIA'S ALLEGELY AND
THEY'LL TRY TO MAKE THIS ALLY
PART OF THEIR RELATIONSHIP EVEN
MORE MEANINGFUL FROM THE RUSSIAN
STANDPOINT AND IT'S VERY LIKELY
THEY COULD ACTUALLY USE THE
FORCES TO MOVE INTO THIS AREA,
SO THE UKRAINIANS ALSO HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL ON THAT FRONT.
>> VERY QUICKLY, WE'RE ALMOST A
YEAR INTO THIS WAR ARE YOU
SURPRISED THEY DIDN'T DO THIS
SOONER.
>> YES, THE BELARUSSIANS, THEY
COULD HAVE USED THESE FORCES BUT
THERE WERE ELEMENTS WITHIN THE
HIGH AR I CAN THAT WERE OPPOSE